hey guys it's time for the most [ __ ]
up Instagram post of the week
[Music]
alright dude
now this one is amazing okay it's just a
guy who is now picture this guy he's
standing near act no he's I don't have
you sitting or stand as a selfie but
he's videoing himself near a kangaroo
the kangaroos in the background just
being a kangaroo okay and it's a video
and the caption is pure amazement so
that's what this guy's good now this is
what this guy is saying I'm just gonna
play the video for you and and he has
got to be a hundred percent high if he's
not it's even better okay this is what
he says these moments in which you
experience a fresh the hardly bearable
act to see of direct energy exploding on
our nerve endings he's of course
referring to a holy moment Otto ranks
mysterium tremendum a Fossen awesome as
tim duty wrote during these moments of
in which we utter exact you lations of
amazement we get to recontextualize the
self as a marvelous conduit in a
timeless hall from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again we transcend the bend there's
and done that's of the adult mind will
not awaken to our common ecstasy other
extractions utter extractions the google
extractions its stack you lations
I mean literally your search extact you
lations did not match any documents have
you ever googled something that's never
had results what a [ __ ] half hard
[ __ ]
this guy is dude this guy's gotten laid
you know this guy has had a conversation
in business he's standing near a
kangaroo I mean what is this guy saying
and he laughs like he's making a joke
like he's like he like did yo dude what
are we gonna play again he talks about
these moments in which you experience
afresh the hardly bearable axe to see of
direct energy exploding on our nerve
endings he's of course referring to a
holy moment Otto ranks mysterium
tremendum if a scene awesome as tim duty
wrote during these moments as a
marvelous conduit in the timeless hall
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and back again we
transcend the bend there's and done
that's of the adult mind we awaken to
our common ecstasy we it literally means
nothing does that mean anything
what does this guy think it means
literally expecting it stack you lations
and transcending the bin there's and
done that and a half knots in the world
Timothy Kaczynski experienced afresh the
hardly directed energy this autorange
experience if sounds so much like a
robot right there
Otto rakes experience in the German do
some mana furious wholesome
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct
energy exploding on our nerve endings
he's of course referring to a holy
moment on anytime someone says of course
like that he's of course referring to
you're a [ __ ] such a [ __ ] dude exact
you lations of amazement have you guys
ever experienced it stack you lations of
amazement about these moments in which
you experienced afresh the hardly
bearable ecstasy of direct energy
exploding on our nerve endings he's of
course referring to a holy moment Otto
ranks mysterium tremendum a facin
awesome as tim duty wrote during these
moments of in which we utter extensions
of amazement in which we utter extact
you lations of amazement let's see what
else it tends to show
Natalia was telling me that she
discovers shots of uh during a time in
her life when she was really kind of
hungry for some kind of answer I smiled
it what a [ __ ] what is happiness I'm
interested in how different places and
spaces and people everything you have to
take into account with your sensory
apparatus informs your subjectivity in
other words your experience has to take
into account where you are and who
you're with right you become what you
behold as McKenna said we are the some
of the people that will spend the most
amount of time with but if we're
interested in we need to be craftsmen of
our fate we need to filter out the wrong
crowd we need to customize our spaces
and places to unfold this is experience
design [ __ ] saying I mean I have egg
stack you lations of amazement right now
doodle what is he saying
just the way he's talking and just we
are just the lump sum of whatever who we
hang out with right so what is exciting
about this hole a paren diem board
sports mortem a podium is basically what
okay so what Galileo said was we're all
walking a mile around and amongst us we
have all the external
hard drive of the mind so to speak it's
well we do we plug into the
extra-terrestrial somewhat of a dark
matter I've been laid four times that
guy probably gets so much a plus dude
IIIi could I here's the thing about me I
can listen to this guy all day and just
be laughing and crying and [ __ ]
loving it now I know that a lot of you
guys are like alright this guy's come on
man don't [ __ ] come on talk about
other things but how can I do that
what there's this guy how can I do that
this guy Fox I like this guy are you
like this guy I actually like this guy
no irony Internet we are drowning in
information every two days we create
more data and all of you in history up
until that point so information keep
therefore intention has become expensive
the currency of our age is attention
attention is the new oil if you can't
retain eyeballs hold on dude what is he
saying like it's Shakespeare
why is he saying it like he's in a Oh
for [ __ ] sake dude oh [ __ ] I gotta hang
out with this guy dude here's the thing
man
this is why I like this guy you have to
be passionate man oh [ __ ] this guy's
blowing my mind not in the way he thinks
he's blowing my mind
this guy is walking down Runyon Canyon
which is a hiking place in Hollywood
doing these these videos I mean he say
since words this guy in a way [ __ ] man
like he said to hold on to their focal
point anything the best part is he
thinks it's funny and he's laughing dude
iiiii I can listen to this guy all day
goddamn and he's so passionate about the
[ __ ] uh oh my god this guy rocks he gets
a follow